for today executive session may be held
on any bills referred to the committee
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and the
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listening
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by a zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general
court's website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call 271 3600
or email hcs ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all the votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also whether there's anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
okay keith you're on okay good morning
everyone
uh calling the role representative hunt
yes i am here and i am by myself
representative yes i am here up in my
room alone
representative osborne
representative ammon here and alone
representative abramson
representative ham
representative de palma
representative greeson present and alone
representative johnson here and alone
representative terry i'm here and i'm
alone
representative bartlett i'm here alone
in the room
representative abel
representative herbert
representative van halton present alone
representative fargo i'm here and i'm
alone
representative weston here and alone in
this room
representative billy here home alone
representative burroughs i'm here and
i'm home alone
representative mcelroy
okay is there anyone that i missed that
joined after i started calling
um bonnie ham okay bunny
and representative herbert didn't unmute
himself
oh
you could read lips so 14 president mr
and yeah i assume chris you're alone
just to be
you're you're still muted and i'm alone
bonnie's alone okay representative
herbert i think you unmuted yourself but
now you've got your microphone way down
yeah the mic we didn't hear
now you got to turn up your microphone i
think you've got it all the way down
no now you're muted
maybe sign language
this is okay so so don you're you're
uh not in the room right i don't see
anybody in the room
no i'm at home today okay
okay all right so we'll open up um
this is a non-domain hearing um on uh
an amendment to senate bill 125. um i
assume everybody has a copy of it it has
my name on it
and the number is 1237. um
and what what i'll do a brief thing and
then
um i will i will then um ask people to
speak who have signed up for it
um basically uh one of the reasons i did
this is the non-germanius are
they're still liquor related
everything's liquor related but the
non-germanius is uh there
are different rsas that were being
brought in then came in in the original
bill
um and but one thing that i was acutely
aware was that we are going to be
mending certain sections
so i really want to make i think i know
got a lot of new members in the
committee so
that this sometimes is a little
complicated so it's important
you know i figured this is a good
learning opportunity so everybody can
follow how we do how happens so when you
look at the bill
at the amendment that have you'll see on
line one
it's it talks about um amending uh by
section five so that means
section one two and three and four are
untouched
in the original bill so if you were to
really follow along what we're passing
or
pass it it said you still need to have
the copy
from the senate of how senate bill 125
and have those sections so then you see
that we're going to be mending section 5
and then if you look on the next
page again then you have section 6 and
then
and this is this is a little confusing
uh some of it's important to follow
um if you get to the the last page page
three
and it will say amend the bill by
inserting
after section seven the following
in renumber sections eight to read as
12.
so you say oh my god well now what
happens okay so now we're going to stick
some
new paragraphs in because we always want
the effective date to be the last line
in the bill okay why i don't know it's
just
just tradition but we don't like it in
the middle of a bill we want it always
at the end
so section eight which was if you were
looking at the original bill
the um effective date that is now number
12.
and so we inserted 8 9 and 10 11. okay
any anybody question yes indeed
representative mclear just called me he
said he is on the call
um he didn't know if there's a way that
pam might be able to help him
come on the panel but he has been on the
call from the beginning
really okay so he must be over the
attendees again so i
just brought him over thank you okay
thanks for letting me know i i did
you're
faster than i am pam well
but okay all right great and then i see
representative abrams is is now with us
hey i have a question i can't find the
raise your hand feature
uh on your screen i don't know what yeah
i'd see my raise my hand is wait is down
at the bottom
where all the where all the icons are
sometimes it's in sometimes it
was another screenshot it was in the
upper right if it's an
ipad um you can also touch the screen
and they um the taskbar should come up
on the bottom
i found that something there's something
else other than raising hand there was
other
like little icons faces that kind of
stuff
so you if you go into there there the
raise the hand is one of the icons
all right this one do you see it here
now we got you
good enough um i still don't have a copy
of the amendment
um i don't see it in my email maybe uh
weeks ago
it well it also uh aiden moore sent it
out
accidentally last night so you might
have to get if you have
if you can just type in aiden in your
search search engine of your email
he did send it out last night one that
just showed up this morning
okay so that's a little different when
he showed up this morning is going to be
a summary sheet
which is really his testimony of what
the amendment does
but if you if you can pull up if you can
pull up what he did
what he said yesterday you'll see the
actual
uh amendment 1237.
i can send it again if you like yeah why
don't you could you do that pam
sure sure all right so let's um
so uh
senator gannon yep senator again i'm
going to now promote him up
and
good morning senator gannon
uh bill are you there
see if this video
let me know the top of my head
uh oh
he disappeared okay so he's gonna have
to try to come back in again
probably uh
[Music]
mr yes good morning uh will he be
testifying
as the uh sponsor of this he is uh he's
detecting the sponsor anybody can you
know when this
this is technically i don't know this is
like a hearing but it's really a
subcommittee meeting
so you know pretty much anybody who want
to weigh in we
will certainly entertain listen to them
um you know
but that um because uh he has seen the
amendment
and wanted to speak towards the
amendment he wanted to assure everybody
that
he's in support that's the reason why he
signed up for it
um so you won't be doing an overview
of what you have so um my overview i'm
gonna let
aiden explain to you what the with the
overreview is
um simpson because he's the one who
really um and i
i i had all the ideas in my head but
he's the one that put it in paper and
put in the words that put the amendment
together
so he was i was going to have him
explain it okay so there's senator
gannon
okay and i'm going to promote the
panelists
let's see if this works this time
good morning senator gannon
then we just love computers
ah can't wait till we get back to normal
so
so mr chair while we're waiting yes
just perhaps save time later on do you
have to know what the science is behind
a maximum of 27 gallons in provision
hold on never mind okay there he is
so to answer just just a second bill uh
the answer is
um pretty much all these numbers
that are in there are just uh statutory
numbers that we have created in the past
and say they were you know i would i
would be honest they were created out of
whole cloth
yes so but i mean i would say that
uh when it comes to the eight the magic
number of eight percent in terms of
of other drinks that number was created
over time based upon what was in the
marketplace
but there's not necessarily any science
behind twenty there's no science on
anything everything the legislature it's
a settled sign
everything's everything is a rabbit
okay senator gannon you're on thank you
um
so where are we at so i read your bill
the only thing i had a question on
uh chairman hunt was um in line
22 through 26 of your amendment
i just didn't and it's probably because
i'm a lawyer and i dwell on small
details it
wasn't clear to me that i could sell at
where
you know my manufacturing plant is and
also at the
one specialty outlet is that clear
enough to you in the writing
so uh actually that would already uh be
in the current statute
okay so you know that's why it was never
addressed in the bill because that
was always it was always the opportunity
to sell in your
manufacturing location okay um so
otherwise i thought your memo was really
good i wish i could draft so
which well me too so i'm not going to re
rep
you know i presented it a week ago um
i'm
relatively happy with what you've done
and um what was my one change i
suggested to on friday
you're wondering why uh nanos nanos
don't have another location
uh oh yeah so why are you because you're
thinking it's not a
bar and it shouldn't be at so many
places you're giving us the one well no
no
the nano it's actually is there's
several several ideas of thoughts about
what's going on with nanos
um first of all the nano license is a
very very very very cheap license
okay as a matter of fact
that so you start off with simply saying
it's okay you get what you pay for so if
you really want to have an extra
location
you should uh you know upgrade to the
big boy license
um and let alone the fact that you're
you're supposed to be
you're supposed to be a nano you're
you're actually supposed you know you're
supposed to be doing this like in your
garage or
you know sort of sort of a hobby so uh
you really you know how can you
be stretching yourself to have two
locations when when it's just supposed
to be a hobby
um and third is that uh the dirty little
secret is is that
because their license is so cheap they
could open
three or four nanos for the price of one
custom brewer so uh there's really no
need and because the nanos are limited
to their production
anyway so so they're really you know the
idea of having
an extra location really doesn't make
any sense at this point can i ask you
one more question
yes um so why can't i team up with if i
own one of these small
nanos why what's the problem with me
teaming up with another
nano and having it like an outlet on
portsmouth so we get exposure
but i'm cutting the cost in half i'd say
that's a concept we should be thinking
about in terms of going future years
about how
multiple locations can have a joint
location
um it notwithstanding that it
technically is a violation of the
three-tier system because what they
would really
want is that location that's being
opened up
is be a uh carrying of carrying all
these different beers
should really be a an off-premise
licensee
and and that's you know not they should
not necessarily be
a beverage location there should be an
off-premise licensee
so the question is does the three-tier
uh you know language we
bar them from having some joint
ownership or join
things but theoretically there's nothing
stopping anybody to
say okay i'm going to open up an
off-premise licensee
and i'm going to carry all these local
local beers and everything like that
there's you know there's nothing
stopping them from doing that now
so the issue is is it ownership and
who's it ownership and how many people i
don't know
we can we can certainly discuss that but
um
at this point anybody can start an
off-premise licensee and
and carry all the beers they want you
know and
have it all self-distributed by all
these new all these different
uh manufacturers which i would hope
somebody would do that frankly but
i don't know i don't know how much of
our market is for that other than that
i'm
very very happy with your amendment okay
great uh representative burroughs has a
question yes um i do have a question
thank you
um in um section
three um we're talking about section
three
talking about the names of addresses of
purchasers to whom the alcoholic
beverages are shipped
i i'm i don't i didn't see this in the
original bill and
what is what is the purpose for that why
do they need to have the
names and addresses of the um consumer
uh so section three
number two the proof uh in the amendment
your time out
yeah okay so there is it's a three
nine four i'm sorry i'm sorry it's in
four it's in four number two okay number
four okay this is direct shipping
yeah so direct shipping means that
somebody is shipping
from their location to um to
somebody in their residence
yes yes so they report to the state
in new hampshire um that so that we we
collected eight percent tax
um we actually have a cross-checking
system which is if they use
ups or fedex we can cross check to see
that that that was properly booked and
entered in and that's the reason why you
have the name and address of where it
was shipped to
follow up please further questions um
how onerous
is that going to be for these companies
it's been the law for 25 years
okay thank you okay
representative mclair um thank you mr
chairman i had that same objection that
anita
has but if it's been the law i don't
see that uh we can change it right now
but i do have another
question and that's on it's the second
page
it's number 32 on page two
so i go into one of these these places
and i can order
one beer and then if i want to order
another beer
i gotta have something to eat and i'm
out of there that
i i don't quite understand that why the
one beer limit
well okay well that's still kind of the
heart of this legislation so i guess we
we should address this all right
so um it it goes back to
at one point in time in history uh if
you were a beverage manufacturer
um you didn't uh you didn't have any
tastings
okay you you didn't nobody came nobody
came into your location at all
and so then we said well we should allow
them to have taste
and the first question is um that
we came up with uh how much can they
taste
so the idea of this tasting the original
taste of tastings
was just the samplers was just four
ounces okay
and you're gonna have four ounces of
whatever they have available for
tastings
so that could be more than 16 ounces if
they have more than four beers let's say
they had six beers so now
that could be six times four but then
some people say no
what people really want is they want to
come in and just have a pint i just want
to have a pint of here
so then we change the legislation to a
pint and at the same time we also
clarified
that whether they could sell this beer
because before those samples were given
away free the law actually
fired that beer and wine and everything
had to be given away free
and so so they'll say well we're giving
a lot of money and this is only
so some people say well we really want
to be able to charge for that pint we
want that full point we want to charge
for it
and that was fine and then the next
debate was to make sure we clarified
that yes
if they're selling that pint of beer
they need to collect the meals tax
you know the old rooms and meals tax so
that was so what you're seeing is
every year we've done these different
steps we could
go down this pipeline now the ultimate
question is well then
gee you see in other states you can have
as many pints as
well you can't have as many as you want
because you might have too many and that
can't they're not allowed to overserve
you
but uh in new hampshire we've always had
this require a food requirement in other
words we're the only state and
i'm certainly in new england and i don't
i don't i really don't know
uh how many different states but we're
really could be the only state in the
union
that requires that uh we don't have bars
okay we just don't have bars you know
they're you know i mean i in my
memory from pittsburgh or even when i
was in college and you know or prep
school at deerfield
when i was actually legal and drink at
18 i'd go into greenville mass and there
was this hole in the wall bar and all it
sold was 50 cent
beers you know and but they would sell
they had no food requirement now in new
hampshire we don't have
that every every facility that sells
alcohol has to have a food requirement
so at what point um when you're talking
about a beverage manufacturer report
how far are we going to go down this
line without this food requirement
so uh what the the compromise and the
way we have kind of negotiated and my
understanding is
that the um the the the brewers these
custom brewers and certainly the neos
they're okay with what we have come up
with what the compromise has been
which is that you can get that one pint
okay you can
i'll get the full pint you get a pint
now if you want that second pint now
they have to be a nano plus then did you
get that little spreadsheet of all the
different that aiden send out it was
very handy and everyone i probably
should have meant to send it out again
but
it was a little handy that it shows you
all the different licenses
and all the different things that
they're required to do so we do have
this nano
plus but the nano plus was not not that
much more in license fee
and but that it did allow to
have that second plane but under the
condition that
the beverage manufacturer would have
somebody there
selling food and so since we know that
that nano shouldn't be in the food
business
so we did allow for food trucks for
instance that you can or you can have
you know bring anybody and
bring someone in who can make food or
sell food um
and so we have that is where the the
political compromise has been over the
years
uh the last couple years is that why we
do it now
at some point you say is well you know
should go beyond two pints and go to the
sky's limit
but i think we're really at the edge now
where we pretty much have got the
agreement that
um this is a reasonable compromise
they're not restaurants they're not
going to go forward and get the full
restaurant license
and they don't want to be in that
business right they're beverage
manufacturers so
does that answer your question
okay and i see connie has a hand her
hand up yes
represent manhattan
daniel needham you unmute
i was trying the space bar and that
didn't work i'm sorry yeah that just
works randomly
i would love to have aiden send that out
again it was really an incredible
resource i'm sure i have one someplace
but if he would send it out again that
would be fantastic
and i'd just like to follow up with what
you're saying because i was around for a
lot of that legislation
and um it it just always kind of
wrinkles my my sensitivities that with
the nano plus you can actually go in and
get a quart of beer and have a bag of
peanuts
um it's um i think we
and then no you can't have a bag of
peanuts all right a couple of bags of
peanuts
and peanut butter on this piece of bread
uh nonetheless food does not have to be
a
staple or a meal or something of that
sort um
and i would like to just reiterate what
i've said before
um and again i've worked on the liquor
bills as you know i
chaired the subcommittee on liquor last
session
and i i really wonder how much we're
putting band-aids on band-aids
and and um given that we had
um we had some recent concerns with the
audit and some changes because of the
audit some changes
outside the audit i really think we have
to start to look at
getting the structure of the three-tier
system intact
before we keep putting band-aids and
band-aids and band-aids and i'm not
necessarily saying that i'm opposed to
some of these things
i like many people enjoy a glass of wine
with my peanuts
however um i i am getting concerned
about that and um
you know once we look at this and start
to say you can have a quart of beer with
a little bit of food
are we are we pushing the limits and
if we don't like the three-tier system
if that needs to be jettisoned
i really think it's time to take a look
at that we've evolved in terms of our
liquor we've evolved in terms of our
economy on the basis of liquor uh we
have restaurants that
that are very supportive of liquor
legislation that helps them to prosper
and bring tourists
uh to our state i worked with john
paduck on a commission for tourism
as it relates to liquor there's so much
out there and and it's no wonder that we
have little questions as we go forward
so thank you for giving me a second for
that little bit of a soapbox but i do
think that there needs to be
something more than just peace peace
peace let's let's get this
fleshed out um and put together so that
it's best for our state
right well i i well one piece i want to
over a is that
uh even before i got involved in the
ever that this issue ever came to
commerce
okay um the three-tier system was
already thrown in the trash can when it
came to
uh brew pups and uh so that
obviously everything we do because it's
mother may i
everything is every step has to be we
have to decide what we're going to allow
and how we rationalize how we allow it
okay
i would say when it comes to the food
requirement and as i've mentioned before
and i'm sure you've heard me say um i
think that the
food requirement was something
that when initially how did they really
think it was that important or was
everybody really conscious of it i don't
know
but i think when when you look at
representative abramson's bill what he's
saying is
you know all right is it do we really
want bacon and eggs and
you know and bread is you know at the at
the convenience store
is that really a judge of what we mean
by the food requirement
so i say almost everything we do with
the liquor law
is is is a progression it changes all
right we have to
way we look at it way we're handling it
way we perceive it
um i certainly i'm gonna say is that
i've tried before
to actually have bars in new hampshire
and i was gonna it was gonna be a
whopping fee but you know if they really
we were gonna have one but uh you know
the bill died and
and and uh and i did another one it was
sort of like to
change the licenses and that bill died
so
um i would say at this point um i i
certainly
think it makes sense and this is just my
opinion
and obviously everybody's entitled their
own opinion that
we want to ensure that this food
requirement is not peanuts it's not
chips
it's anything that rooms and meat room
meals tax
is taxing so if meals tax is very
that statue is very distinctive and very
big and i'll never forget it because i
was around i was in the house at the
time
when we were debating what they called
the snack tax
okay that what was going to be in the
middle tax and was snacks like when you
buy from a machine or it was a you know
the peanut butter and crackers or
peanuts and stuff
and that was the clear decision that um
those
are not meals they're not
necessarily healthy foods right that and
so that was never
that was not included in the meals tax
but that the meals tax really
was going to be as well distinctive it
had to be
it had there had to be a little bit of
cooking involved there had to be some
heating things up and then
and that like i say that um to me is the
direction i think we should go
in in firming up that uh you know that
people um you know have some kind of
foods and
my understanding is that uh that
tuckerman's
is is now you know they're they're
they're doing paninis
which is really easy piece of bread you
get the cheese you squeeze it
stick it in and voila they got a nice
sandwich and it's healthy for you and
it's a good sandwich and i think that's
you know
shows that we're making progress on this
issue so i'm not overly worried about
the
food concern but in terms of the
three-tier and what the you know
how does three tier really mean much in
this whole scheme of things um
i don't know it's uh it's a concept but
you know we've obviously have we've got
we've worked so many
loopholes around around it and so many
things around it i'm
i'm not sure that i would say that we i
would fall um i swear on defending
defending the three-tier uh i think max
had
the next one to have his hand up so
representative abramson i was just going
to make a quick comment on this
three-tiered system
i thought of putting together a study
committee bill on that but i think it
would be i would i would rather go back
to your original idea
of splitting the commerce committee into
three you know i have the liquor
you know alcohol related laws group but
to have that
i was wondering if we could have that
group meet over the summer and review
the the
all the three-tier issue problems um
and and take input from members and see
what they want to do with the food
requirement if they want to keep the
three-tier system or go to something
proportionate or what have you
yeah you know that's absolutely
absolutely what my plan is that we'll
we'll have our divisions the three
divisions
and so we'll go forward come next fall
based on those three divisions
and uh and and the liquor one is free to
talk about whatever they want to talk
about
uh and so yes no that that's absolutely
what i'm thinking about doing max thank
you
did you have a date or uh or not a date
but a
general ballpark of when and how often
do you want to meet
again i'm i'm i'm assuming that you know
that i don't know what you know again
july and august we've always
stayed out of the house so i'm assuming
that come september
we'll all be back and then i'll have
they'll
each each division will have its own
chairman and
we'll call the meetings work with the
people to in terms of calling meetings i
know some people want to take vacations
in september and october so we obviously
want to be flexible with that when
which each subcommittee and uh and what
they're doing on vacation time but
um so so but yes i would say i
would be in person come september i'd
i'd like to have at least one or two
meetings before that because uh
in order to introduce bills for next
year i'm also one of the co-chairs on
the vegas caucus which proposes uh
you know repealing certain laws and
legalizing certain things
um so i'd like to have some meetings and
and and have some input and discuss
ideas rather than introduce a bill
find out if there's actually any
interest from the committee in putting
some of these bills in okay well i'll
start working on it right now and get it
together
okay representative bilo yeah thank you
mr chair
i'm just wondering if the restaurant and
lodging association um
are they around today so they did not
sign up
um i see henry is there so and i don't
know
the summers is there so um i can sure we
can get we can get henry to
maybe convince him to speak yeah because
i think
this bill um i think they really should
be speaking up because it will affect
the restaurant lodging association
uh my understanding is that they did
wave
i've crafted this amendment and working
working with the commission that they
are they are this
follows with the guidelines it doesn't
change anything from what they're doing
and
and actually gives them a new
opportunity to actually get direct
shipping
to them so so it actually gives them
something that they didn't have before
but okay is that's it for the committee
all right so i will now
call the next person and sign up was i
was going to call
well i don't know henry uh you know
uh henry rave your hand if you want to
talk otherwise if you feel like you
don't have anything to say don't bother
and i will call on right now who has
signed up
is the groceries association and i will
promote them
and good morning morning mr chairman
good morning john how are you very well
thank you i'm trying to get my video up
there
that important i don't know if it is or
not but
there we go there you are thank you
mr chairman for inviting us to come back
and be part of this
we appreciate that um i've been
following this uh
all morning long and i think that it's a
very
informative discussion you're having
especially on the three-tier system
and i think it everyone understands that
the three-tier system
started back with the end of prohibition
the reason for prohibition was that
during that time
uh there was a lot of bootlegging that
was going on and it was just a wild west
of everything
and when they decided to repeal
prohibition they came up with the
concept of the three-tier system to
protect the fact that a manufacturer
could would not be a wholesaler
and a wholesaler would not be a retailer
therefore
having certain chinese walls if you want
to call it that between the different
factions of a production and
distribution of alcoholic beverages
and that's that's served us well for all
these years
that there's a reason why there's a
three-tier system
and and so we would certainly support
that we always have supported that
our association was formed back in 1933
uh when we saw this coming and it was a
concern that we wanted to see the 3g
system to protect
all three entities in in the process of
doing that going forward
i also want to just thanks well i have
the time to do this to thank
you mr chairman and members of the
committee for the work you've done
on this amendment and this other part uh
we are very much supportive of
everything you're doing with this
it's exactly what we would like to see
happen to protect that
the other part is talk about the food
requirement
there's a concern with that that
restaurant lodging is has
issued as long as we have too that we're
concerned about drinking
without any food consumption and that
when you take food into consideration
with that
absorbing some of that you're having
less likely
being being impaired during the process
so there is a reason for it's not
protecting anything in particular it's
more of protecting the public from
drunk drivers
great um are you willing to take a
question because i absolutely
represented van gaal do you have a
question for actually
not i have a comment that i would like
to address to you
okay okay
two issues um again you know my
attention
to uh language detail and um
in the amendment in line seven on page
one
the permit shall authorize the holder to
sell and delivery
alcohol beverages i believe the word
should be delivered
in order to make the amendment correct
this is line seven line seven page one
to sell in the deliver
okay all right
and while i'm at it on page two line
four i would just like to
mention a um something that i often um
comment about because it is bothersome
to me
the words in a timely manner i never
know how we define that
is a timely manner one day one year one
month
uh how does one define that i realize
that that
that's a very difficult concept to deal
with but leaving something open-ended
like that has always been um
an affront to my sensibility of language
okay uh i think in timely matter is the
eyes of the beholder
so but okay and then deliver versus
delivery um
you know theoretically we should correct
that but uh just so for everybody knows
there is another entity a step
uh before bills go get signed by the
governor and it's called enrolled bills
it's a part of the legislative
administration committee
which i i did have the
fortune to be the chair for one term in
which the enrolled committee
uh would go through anything that of
those kind of typos
and correct them so there is a process
but i i would i yes we would try to
correct it and while i'm aware of that
our integrity is our as a committee is
always on the line and we want to be the
best that we can be
we want to be good wordsmiths
okay all right uh so
uh henry did not put his hand up so i
guess he doesn't
necessarily want to share so i will ask
aiden moore to
go through um the amendment and uh
and be able to answer any specific
questions that anybody might have
so you are you're on a oh look at that
fancy library
i have all those books at home
i uh thank you uh mr chairman and
committee members and first let me uh
apologize for the flurry of emails that
you received from me this morning
in an attempt to uh get you this
information
accurately uh i think my last email was
uh accomplish that task thanks to pam
smarling for putting me on the right
path here um thank you chairman for
explaining that your amendment one two
three seven
lies on top of senator gannon's
amendment zero seven four five which i
think
will help in case anyone has any
questions about
if these parts need to be looked at in a
whole
as in the whole fashion um
on the amendment your amendment one two
three
seven uh mr chairman hud um
we're looking at page three excuse me
page one
line three where we now have established
a new provision in statute
called the direct to consumer shipments
of alcohol
now to have this make any sense
members of the committee you need to
know that rsa 178 27
is the direct shipping statute and we
talked a little bit about trying to
fit the ability for
licensees in new hampshire to send
products to
new hampshire consumers by amending
178.27
and that didn't really make it make much
sense it would it would have created
some type of a
colossus statute and so therefore the
approach that we took was to
take the pieces out of 178.27
and i forget which representative asked
the question
of why the i think it might have been
representative burroughs
who was asking the question about
reporting
and keeping names etc and
what you see in this provision
which starts and ends
on page 2 line 16
is is essentially an incorporation of
much of the language from 178.27
into this new statute all the reporting
requirements all the
packaging requirements all the signature
requirements that exist
in the law which applies to businesses
who
are existing out of state and ship into
new hampshire
would now apply to businesses located in
shipping to new hampshire consumers so
we've we've brought all those pieces
across
often times when legislation and alcohol
is introduced there are questions about
parity
and is is is it equal
and so therefore what we've proposed
here
in this amendment is to bring all the
limitations
and i think in the executive
summary you see the limitations on
quantity and
those quantity limitations which exist
in the direct shipping law
have also been brought across and
applied
in the direct-to-consumer piece that's
being proposed
in the 178-27b section
[Music]
so with that i guess mr chairman
i if you'd like i can pause and take any
questions from members about this
particular piece
um or just wait to the end um
okay so that's we'll say any questions
so uh representative bartlett did you
have a question
i do and i'm sorry to interrupt but um i
was looking at the executive summary
um and mr moore it it refers to
amendment
um 1191 but the
amendment that we're looking at is 12 37
correct that that's correct and i think
the that's
part of the flurry of emails i sent this
morning which i the last one you
received from me was the correct one and
i apologize for
any inconvenience i've caused you i'm
sorry then i
i'll go back and and print it out sorry
okay my apologies ma'am
yes yeah there wasn't wasn't a big
change between the two
okay uh uh representative burroughs
yes mr moore thanks for taking my
question um i understand what you're
saying about parity between
out of state and and the in-state um
shipping
my question is i'm i'm i'm i'm just kind
of trying to understand
why the limitations of say 60 individual
containers in a calendar year
because i'm thinking of a scenario where
somebody's having a home wedding
um which is pretty common and that
doesn't seem like a lot of liquor if
you're having
over 100 people for for a home wedding
something like that
oh thanks for your question
representative i i think
what you're seeing in this amendment is
a a gap filler there's there's no
limitation on the
person that you've described in your in
your scenario
who can go to uh for example a
convenience store
purchase as much as they wish they could
go to a beverage wholesaler
versus purchase as much as they wish
in the amendment 0745
from senator gannon we've removed
the limitations that were imposed upon a
beverage manufacturer
which up to this point in time was
limited to selling an individual case or
a 15.5 gallon
keg that's been removed in the bill
so we've essentially stripped the
limitations
away and and if you think of
178 27b as really
rounding out the entire process this
this was kind of an area that was really
not touched uh mr dumas and his members
for example
could deliver any of one of his members
can
uh deliver to a consumer and and has
had that ability and to just kind of
reference who this applies to if you
look on page one of the amendment
lines five and six that
this direct-to-consumer piece is really
now
applicable to manufacturers nano brewers
brew pubs wine manufacturers liquor
manufacturers and beverage distributors
so these are the class of licensees now
who will be allowed to
proceed to ship directly to consumers
within the state
following the provisions below regarding
the
time place and manner that this is
supposed to happen
so i i hope i hope i've answered your
question representative if not i'll be
happy to try
to do it again um yeah i don't i don't
want to belabor it but i'm just
again i'm still struggling to understand
i understand that it's okay
so i i can answer this question
the answer is very simple actually and
and
and aiden was probably would not if he
want to say this but
this was the political compromise for me
to get the direct shipping pass
because we don't you know the liquor
commission
doesn't want you to be buying wine
directly from california
they want you to come to our liquor
stores and and buy it from us
so the issue was at how much can they
ship to you as the consumer and
and and be reasonable you know not not
have a
dent in our overall revenue source which
is the liquor commission
so these numbers were are set really
where was that it was a balancing add to
what is
how much is appropriate how much is
enough yeah it is true if you plan to
have a big old wedding
and you want to have certain beer that
you can't
get in new hampshire um and you want to
take advantage of you know the 60 year
i guess you would just have to have
family members somebody else also
with a different address also order it
so enough you order
definitely maybe you can get enough but
the idea was that we didn't want
uh we didn't want any any outside
manufacturer outside the state and to
think
that this is an opportunity to bypass
their our distribution system or our
liquor commission
and that's that's the real thank you
that makes total sense now thank you
very much
okay uh representative mcaleer
uh thank you mr chairman i'm i'm looking
through this
and i don't see anything maybe i'm
missing it about
uh new hampshire brewers etc shipping
out of state
that's potential that's exactly what
this section is
uh is is this intra state shipment is uh
which well actually put this away the
direct shipping law was um
is is uh limit is currently
being used by beverage manufacturers
so a beverage manufacturer right now can
ship
beer or anything out of state
and that's using the direct shipping law
with this statue
is what you're seeing here is just
interstate
and that that was a uh you know uh i
guess you could say a loophole
but that um and but we could have just
simply said okay fine we'll allow them
be this in the same direct shipping law
but then i didn't really want double
taxation i mean i
i want be able to if a new hampshire
citizen to be able to
get beer or get a wine or beer having
shipped to them and not have to pay the
eight percent tax
so but the question you're asking is can
they now ship out of state
and yes they can but that's in the
direct shipping law which is not
uh it's not in this bill
my point is can they ship more out of
state than they can ship
interstate there's no limitation
mr chairman may i follow up with that
yes the the representative mclear the
the businesses in new hampshire can ship
out of state so long as they
uh follow the requirements in those
existing states to which they ship
who may have their own the other state
that's the problem similar
so for example while we have rsa 178 27
for businesses who
ship into new hampshire other states may
have similar legislation
prescribing how a business located
outside of their
state lines what they must do
to ship to consumers within their state
so this is a this is a state by state
issue and our direct shipping
really only addresses people shipping
within into the state
and 178 27 b
kind of rounds out that piece as it
relates to businesses
shipping to consumers within the state
okay all right great
uh representative emman uh thank you mr
chair
and uh thank you uh mr moore for taking
our questions and
listening to our concerns um
i'm surprised to hear uh that the state
is collecting
names and addresses of people receiving
shipments
and you know thinking about privacy
aspect of this
i understand that it might be uh a way
to enforce this
60 container limit is that correct no
it's really
the enforce a is that the person is
actually
who the person is who's getting it and
we want to make sure that they really
are over 21
but more importantly we also want to
make sure that the tax is getting paid
so we actually get this information also
from ups fedex
when they deliver it they're going gonna
they'll report back to us
so we can match up that with the
corp the businesses who are collecting
the eight percent so we can make sure
that the eight percent actually got
collected
will you follow up yes follow further
question inquire so
what what data exactly is collected how
is it stored
what's the security around it and how is
it disposed of
uh well we don't have any credit card
numbers all we would have
is the person's name and address but i
don't know
i don't know hayden do we know how the
the
security is transactional information is
really between the consumer
and the licensee so we don't keep
that as representative fund indicated
this is information is requested to
provide us with an opportunity to
investigate if we need to
on enforcing for example the limits so
uh direct shipping 178.27
uh imposes limits and imposes a tax as
representative hunt said
so if if we were finding that businesses
were shipping into the state
there are two concerns first are they
paying us what their
oh what we what we are owed based upon
these transactions
and secondly by the numbers that are
involved
there are provisions in 178.27 that tell
these businesses for example
as chairman hunt said we want consumers
in new hampshire to buy from the state
liquor commission
but if there's a product that they can't
get that is shipped into the state
these uh limitations are imposed to
essentially say to the commission
um hey you know we didn't know that this
was going to be that popular
so if you're shipping enough of it into
the state that it's creating a demand
then you need to sell it to us too and
now we're going to put it on our shelves
so that is kind of a hook in there to
to allow the businesses to ship in but
also to give the commission the
opportunity to acquire the product to
sell
on their shelves
yes so so in order to
to uh to police the businesses
you're surreptitiously collecting data
on private citizens
that's what i'm hearing you saying it
wouldn't be stereotypicious because we
would be
asking them for the information if there
wer if there was an inkling that there
was a problem going on you're asking the
business the consumer doesn't know
the data is being collected and i'm
assuming it's being stored in some kind
of database that you could search later
right
is that correct no well no there would
be the business has it it would be
the commission would then is requiring
them to hold on to that information so
that
the commission can ask for it if they um
if they need to do an audit or some have
have some reason to
investigate i mean this is what you know
so it is it's you know we don't we're
not getting it automatically
you know we're not that that would we
certainly our computers would never be
able to handle that
now we're we we're only using upon
requests if there was an issue
situation audited and you know that and
but like you say that they
the deal the other thing that aiden
pointed out was really important to the
liquor commission was
that you know we don't want you know
like opus one
you know to suddenly say well because we
only sell so much of it
we'll sell it directly we'll bypass the
liquor commission completely
and that that that they didn't that
that defeat the whole purpose of the
bill which was was not was was supposed
to find things that
not people that we didn't know we we
didn't know that people want
and so therefore this is a way to test
market and see if there is an interest
in the product and if there is
then of course we want the commission to
be able to get it so one last follow-up
i know this is my
my fourth or fifth is that okay yeah
it's fine
uh so how do they know how does the
liquor commission
know the demand for a product they're
not carrying
if they're not accessing that data
we're getting a report from fedex and
ups
it doesn't have the names and addresses
on it they're telling us what they're
what they're delivering
we get i think we get the invoices don't
we we get the inventory
the the direct shippers are required to
file a monthly report
um as is required here in the amendment
for 17827b
where they would file monthly and tell
the commission
who they're shipping to in new hampshire
and the limitations are again imposed
largely for the commercial purposes of
determining whether or not this is a
product
the commission wants to put on its
shelves if it doesn't have it on it now
so monthly you're getting names and
addresses of
from every shipper for everything they
ship
that's what they're supposed to report
to the commission that's correct
so if you don't want pers you don't want
anybody to know that don't
buy don't don't buy up the internet
anyways right so my initial supposition
was correct
yes i would say yes now that i now i
hear that i i would say you're
you're correct that yes we actually have
the names and addresses to all those new
hampshire citizens
so that means neil kirk mr privacy
because i know
he'd like to buy the wine you know off
the new york times or the the wall
street journal
so yes that we would have their names
and names and addresses
that is true so
if you if you want privacy don't don't
order to the through the mail
don't internet so
okay uh representative uh let's see uh
greece in your this is new for you to
ask a question
well thank you mr chairman i guess it
goes to the to the privacy issue there
would it be possible to add something
into the bill that says that the
commissioner has to destroy the
information
after it's verified that taxes have been
collected
um i i would assume that they they would
destroy the evidence after
what if they wouldn't call this habit
they would destroy this data after a
certain point in time but
we can find that out right aidan we can
find out how long we'll hold on to that
information
oh yes yes we can so we we get that for
you but i i mean i'm
i'm sure they're not stacking it all in
warehouses well you know
intentionally that would be it it's it's
computerized so it would be
well i i can't say it's computerized
because not all of the alcohol industry
is
computerized so we may get faxes we may
get emails
but that information is compiled by the
commission's examiner unit
for the purposes of um doing a
comparison to ensure the revenues are
where they're supposed to be
okay so you all said jeff
i guess so i guess i live under the fear
of my principle still having my
record as a kid but i guess not i i like
best advice
is if you're if you're worried about
that your name and address being
somewhere i would not be buying anything
off the internet
yeah i understand that but if we just
put a clause in there that they have to
to
destroy it after sorry but let's find
out let's find out how long they hold on
to that
but okay uh representative herbert
uh we still can't hear you
you're not muted chris so it's obviously
your volume or where's your microphone
or
would you please his earpiece doesn't
look like he has a microphone in it
which might be the problem
does he have an earpiece oh yeah i guess
you got headphones on there
chris yeah so unplug those things
unplugged
does this make a difference yes now it
works
okay that's absolutely what it was it's
a problem you have no microphone in your
headset
okay uh the reason i uh i'm i'm uh
talking is the issue of
the shippers giving information to
the state in regards to is it just
liquor shipments or is it every shipment
thicker yeah this is just liquor okay so
i'd well you would say liquor it's a
beer and wine i don't know what you mean
by well alcohol i
i just uh the way it was stated is
almost as though
fedex and ups had to give you their
daily
shipment whatever and i'm going well
that's nuts
all we care about is alcohol well yeah i
understand that
all right representing back later um
just thank you uh
mr moore how often are these violations
of how commonplace
is a violation
uh thank you for your question
representative um
we are constantly looking to make sure
that the
the revenues provided by the
out-of-state
direct shippers are
where they're supposed to be um and
because i think there are over a
thousand direct shippers that are
currently
licensed and authorized to ship into new
hampshire you can well imagine
um and especially those who are
relatively small
don't ship a lot of quantity might say
well you know
we're going to skip this we're not going
to we're not going to identify this so
we're in a constant process of of
checking so actual violations
in the sense that um let's say for
example
the aside from the revenue piece the
other consideration
are that alcohol is shipped to people
who are of appropriate
age and so therefore
our enforcement unit will periodically
audit
those records to make sure that the
alcohol is being properly shipped
to those consumers who are of 21 or
older
in new hampshire so i can't give you a
precise number of how many
violations occur each year sir but i can
tell you that
it is uh regularly monitored
to ensure that the businesses who are
licensed aren't compliant
and uh i do have some information mr
chairman that
the direct the shipping information
that's provided
is kept for the current uh year
plus one in house and then those records
then go to uh
archives uh state archives for five
years
okay
all right uh any other
questions all right so we're on to
section two eight
thank you mr chairman um section two
of the amendment 12
37 deals with
on page two it's number six on line 20.
and in this it uh
as the chairman explained the the
sampling piece here is not the new piece
the new piece
is that uh under this amendment
provision a beverage
manufacturer would be allowed for a fee
of 336 dollars to acquire
a single
beverage manufacturer retail outlet
so with that and at the
beverage manufacturer's retail outlet
the consumer who came in to visit
could have a sample the sample of their
product
could be a four ounce sample per
label it could be a single
16 ounce pint of their product
and if the location were to provide
food then they could have a second
16 ounce pint as a part of their
sampling
the beverage manufacturer would only be
allowed to sell
their products they could not sell
products from any other business
and the food that is provided could come
and be made in-house or it could be
purchased from
another source and made available
if they wanted to allow consumers to
have a second pint
so there is a definition
of what a beverage manufacturer
retail outlet is and
that exists on senator gannon's
amendment 745 s
on page 4 line 31
which defines a beverage manufacturer
retail outlet as an outlet for the sale
sampling production or manufacturing
and promotion of beverages and products
manufactured by the beverage
manufacturer licensee
the way this is written it requires
the beverage manufacturer who applies
for a beverage manufacturer retail
outlet
to produce beverages
on the facility at the facility site of
the facility
so there is a production requirement
that is
exists in the definition
which would be required
and applied under the amendment
on line 20 number six
and i'm happy to take any questions
chairman on that provision
okay any questions
representative do you have a question
yes i do thank you mr chair
um are you talking about it um
a brewery what what type of
business are you talking about a
beverage manufacturer it sounds like
you're talking about
it's a bed beverage manufacturer but
it's also a restaurant but
not not really i just it's that's a
brewpub
thank you for your question
representative to to help um
make this as clear as i can from a
beverage manufacturing and when i say
beverage it's
it's beer it's something called a
specialty beverage which
hasn't it's a a whole definitional issue
but we have essentially for the purposes
of beer there are three different
categories of license that one can
acquire right
right a beverage manufacturer license
which is the title
of that license a
smaller incubator type of business is a
nano brewery and then the third type
of manufacturer would be a brewpub
so when we speak of beverage
manufacturer we're speaking specifically
of the license under rsa 178
12.
the businesses that hold that type of
license
a nano brewer for example would hold a
license under 178 12
a so the the beverage manufacturer
phrase is actually term of art as
it applies to this provision
a term of art it has a specific meaning
it's it's not used generically beverage
manufacturers are defined in
in the law under rsa 178.1 excuse me 175
colon one
and so therefore the provisions that
are contained in the amendment allowing
for a beverage manufacturer retail
outlet
only apply to that type of business
so if they're going to be selling food
um will they need to get a license from
the department of health if they're
going to sell it
um yes i mean we're we're looking at
this for example that the
uh third-party vendor who sells them has
to be a properly licensed vendor
so if uh i'll try to use this
uh explain us through an example uh i'm
a beverage i'm manufacturer abc i take
advantage of this
opportunity i pay my 336 dollars
i go and find a location for my retail
outlet
i open it up i have production capacity
uh initially i decide i want to do four
ounce samples
which they can do they can give it away
as the chairman mentioned
or sell it if they decide i want to
do pints as well well they could do that
as well
if they decide they want to go further
into the sense of providing a second
16 ounce beverage then they have to
provide food
and that goes to the discussion that the
chairman had with you all about
uh the importance of food in the process
and that it's important to try to
prevent
over service and that food oftentimes
tempers the effects of alcohol so
the food that they provide can be
produced by them
and if so depending upon the type of
food that they offer
if they make it there then they would
have to require
and comply with the health requirements
for that community
if it's pre-packaged then they probably
would not
um but they could also acquire their
products
for example from a third party so maybe
there's a
caterer down the street who they have
developed a rapport with who says i'd
like to
i'd like you to sell my stuff here and
then if if that goes over well they can
come down the street and buy it from me
so there's an opportunity here for
for the business to sell products that
are already produced
outside of their facility or produced
inside
or prepackaged materials
wow okay
all right representative johnson do you
have a question
yeah so i'm i'm just trying i'm new to
the committee thank you for taking my
question so i'm just trying to wrap my
head around all of this
i've been listening so intently so my
question is
so if i am a buisso example
and i have i want to
let somebody put my beer out there i can
only let
one retail outlet sell my beer i can't
go
no okay you can you can have anybody
anybody who's an
uh off-premise licensee can sell your
beer for you
what this is you want to own
that location okay and the three-tier
remember
the magic of the three-tier for what it
was worth was you that was these chinese
walls between
manufacturing distribution and retail
and how it's sold so what that this is a
you know slight trampling of the system
which we're going to say
if you're a manufacturer you can
actually
own a retail location an off-premise
license
and uh but that you know they're
obviously if you have food you're going
to have to make sure that you know the
food is
whoever's providing the food or whatever
you're doing is properly licensed in
that town whatever the zoning is in that
town
about that food but no you can sell your
beer to anybody
it's if you want to own that satellite
location
okay thank you that was i was getting
confused i couldn't understand this
it's taken me many years to get my arms
around all this
so okay any other questions for aiden on
part two all right part three
thank you mr chairman uh on on the
amendment
uh on page three uh
line four through eight uh
number eight uh direct to consumer
shipping
permit
178 27 b
is that is the nuts and bolts the guts
around
having those licensees who are listed
there shipped directly
to new hampshire consumers this
particular section
would now enable a business
uh it creates a business opportunity
quite frankly for anyone who might want
to engage in this
but it does require that the shipment
that is made to the consumer
be made by a licensed carrier
the commission issues a carrier's
license
and i guess most commonly you might look
at it from the standpoint of
uh if you see the beer trucks going down
the highway
each of those beer trucks is issued a
carrier's license
from the liquor commission um so
therefore
the decision was made that
for the businesses who choose to engage
in the
direct to consumer shipping within the
state must
do so by using a licensed carrier
and that's what this provision does
okay and they're all pretty much used to
that anyways because if they were doing
um self distribution they would have
already had the number
already gotten registered their vehicles
right sure correct
okay any questions there
all right that's an easy one um the next
issue
is uh on page three number nine
and you'll see this is a new provision
which is not
in the amendment 745 s
um this changes and expands the
definition of a beverage
um this is a very
convoluted area um and
one that has seen uh
revision probably uh over the last few
years almost every year
some of it has to do with the
static issues that existed within the
law
obviously as legislators you create a
law it's a snapshot in time it
addresses an issue as it exists today
businesses who are in the process of
manufacturing
beverages wine liquor beer
are constantly experimenting
developing new products new methods of
manufacturing
and it's somewhat difficult for the
laws to keep up with the businesses that
are
in the business of producing alcohol so
this change is uh brought about
by a change in the manufacturing process
uh where manufacturers now are producing
a beverage not necessarily
um using the traditional
malt products but fermenting it or
brewing
these products now with other
ingredients such as
sugar this change
will now allow those products which up
to this point in time have not been
eligible for the new hampshire
marketplace to come in
and these products would come to the
retailer
and the new hampshire consumer by means
of
new hampshire beverage wholesalers so
that's how the product would come in
the vendor would sell it and and again
this applies to
any of our licensees who are eligible to
produce this so it's not necessarily
just
people who are exist out of state this
is
uh applies to our new hampshire beverage
manufacturer
it applies to the nano brewer it applies
to the brew pub
all of them now are able to produce
products
based on this definition and get them
into the marketplace
uh either by self-distribution or moving
them to the beverage wholesaler
uh supply side to get it to the consumer
that may be a little more convoluted
that's almost as common as a definition
okay we have
we have two different tax rates out
there and we have
the the beer tax which is 30 cents a
gallon and then we have those things
that are distilled
uh or wine based that uh potentially
are are five percent of the wholesale
price
and so what we're having is a this is a
particular product
and generally i don't say names but um
it's a it's a spritzer and um it
basically
they we already did it with mike's hard
lemonade well we went to the eight
percent
so this is a spritzer that's now going
to eight percent um
it theoretically could have been treated
as
a as a sort of as a distilled uh type
product
so what we're doing is we're expanding
our definition of
exactly who is under the eight percent
who you know
is originally was just flavored malt
beverages and we thought we were all set
with the malls
but it turns out that there's always a
new way to
mix up something and so this is going to
help address that
but just keeps the channels consistent
to what we have right now in terms of
the the beer distributors uh this is the
product that the beer distributors can
distribute at the 30 cents a gallon
rather than worried about the five
percent tax
so any questions on this one so this is
this piece is part of the reason why
this i'm calling this a non-germain
hearing because
this was not and really in the bills but
it really is also the same
subject of what we're trying to do here
which is to get more product in the
hands of
retailers
okay on to the next section thank you mr
chairman
on page three line twenty
number ten uh as as the chairman
mentioned
um in the discussion earlier
the sampling issue has kind of evolved
over time
and he did a very nice job of describing
its evolution
one of the this bill this section
proposes to
provide nano brewers with the same
privileges that
exist for beverage manufacturers
if you recall the beverage manufacturer
can serve either
four ounce samples or a 16 ounce pint
if they wish then to serve a second
16 ounce pint they must have food
available
nano brewers under the current law
are limited to four ounce samples only
and this amendment would propose to
change that so that
all of the manufacturers would be able
to serve the same
amount under the same conditions
hence the parity
and that's right four and five
i mean that's two seconds um
um this would be lines 20 through 25.
questions on this
okay and the last piece mr chairman
is line 26 number 11.
um under the direct shipping
provisions of 178.27
excuse me mr chairman i think
representative herbert has
represented herbert do you have a
question on a previous section
yes sir um just to
clarify the uh under the same conditions
and and then
uh chairman hunt uh said uh parody
and uh i'm wondering is there a uh
i mean in the restaurant business
there's like what that 10 percent rule
uh you have to have so much uh food if
you're selling food
uh per um
you know it it's it's a rule you have to
have the food there at 10
or more so is that is that the measure
that you're talking about here uh no sir
okay um a a nano brewer
has a couple of options they under the
current law
they can serve four ounce samples to
consumers who come in
try their product and
if they wanted to then uh allow the
consumer to sit down
and consume alcohol just like they would
in any other facility
they have to acquire a
another license which is built into
their statute
that gives them the eligibility to apply
for a license under 178.20 which is a
restaurant license that serves
beer and wine and if they acquire that
for 240 which is half the price
of any other business that were to
acquire that license
then they could now sell
um with food
with with the um
anything that would could be considered
food uh
a products to their consumer so
what rather than we've kind of
introduced in this particular section
that middle ground which would allow a
nano brewer to say
you know i'm not ready to acquire i
don't necessarily want to get into the
food area but i still want people to be
able to have that experience of sitting
down drinking a pint
and and maybe even a second pint so
with this change they would be allowed
to do that moving forward
if they wanted to have that person have
a third pint
then they would still need to acquire
that license under 178.20
to achieve that uh result
so it's kind of incremental
depending upon where they see their
business going how they want their
business to evolve
if they want to just provide samples
they can do that
if they want to create more of a
sit-down experience where someone can
have
one maybe two then food needs to be
present and if they really want to
create that
pub type environment then they can
acquire that restaurant license under
178.20
excuse me which would allow them to
operate as any other restaurant would
operate
so if they acquired that other license
they would
i'm sorry further question chairman
so um i haven't heard you say anything
about
a ratio of food to alcohol
and that's does that not exist
that does not exist sir um if
if you in way back when uh
i it did um i i
first came to work for the commission
1981 and uh
that existed at that time uh
restaurants that are obligated to sell
any type of
uh limit are subject to limitations
are licenses that licensees that sell
liquor
so they need to be able to sell
and demonstrate to the commission
annually that they sell
seventy five thousand dollars worth of
food to be eligible to hold a license
that
allows them to sell spirits
correct but but there is but there is no
ratio
in the law and hasn't been for something
oh yeah
right okay joel joel winters and if you
remember joel winters he sponsored that
bill to
fix that problem many many moons ago
okay last but not least
uh thank you mr chairman the last piece
is to repeal
a limitation that existed in the law for
direct shippers
under 178.27 and again direct shippers
are those who businesses license who
exist out of state who are shipping in
to new hampshire
and in the law there was a limitation
that prevented these out-of-state
shippers from shipping
beer to new hampshire licensees
and this amendment changes that
and allows now
these licensees to order beer
from out-of-state direct shippers if
they want to maybe there's a product
that
they can't get in new hampshire that
exists out of state they could order it
and bring it in
so this this would be removing the
limitation that exists now
and allowing licensees to be able to
purchase out of state just as any
consumer would
with the limitations with the
limitations correct the caps
okay any questions there
all right um great thank you very much
aidan
um so just to wrap up everyone um one of
the things i have also been kind of
you know thinking about is uh we have
another liquor bill
that has two items in it that's also
in this bill as it came over from the
senate
um i don't know what's that other senate
bill
in the uh one amendment one zero seven
four five s
no no i'm saying the um the other senate
bill that's got the has the dollar oh
i'm sorry eighteen i believe
so that has the doggies but it also has
these other two sections already in this
bill which is the
um uh tenant tenant brewer and the
contract brewing for uh excuse me uh mr
chairs
senate bill 17 i believe 17. okay so
that bill has the the other two issues
of the contract brew
and the tenant brew are in this bill so
i'm
i'm just going to point out to think
that the doggy issue
i'm not sure we have seen the ends of
dogs
and this it's really um there's all
kinds of things out
my attitude would be is that bill we
would just uh retain that bill
so that the liquor committee can talk
about dogs until they're blue in their
face
and then um and then we'll just make
sure that both the tenant and
and the contract is also still in this
build and we'll leave it right in there
um and that way this can be our omnibus
liquor bill for this session so which
i'm sure the senate will just love
but all right other than that anybody
have any other questions so um
based upon a little bit of a survey we
had here it sounds like people are a
little busy in the first couple of days
of next week
so i'm going to aim thinking that i'm
going to have a exec session on
thursday does anybody have a problem
with doing
thursdays will the senators don't need
to see see
what we're doing they'll be busy having
their own session so they don't need to
see us
so um i will so uh stay tuned for
getting that notice
and uh and we'll go go from there uh yes
representative abramson um i'm fine with
uh thursday but
um i'm working on an amendment or i'm
having legislative services work on an
amendment for senate bill
97 uh and i don't know what the language
is going to be for that
uh they said that they were going to try
and get it over to today but i don't
have it yet
um so as soon as i have it i'll send it
out um
uh to the rest of the committee members
yeah that would be great
uh and then i do have a hint okay try
okay uh kate frye will
want to uh wants to have the last word
there she is hi kate good morning kay
can you hear me okay yes we can um i'm
sorry i signed up earlier to testify so
i'm sorry i
did not see that sorry okay um sorry
about that
so i guess i i i had testimony
planned and i am so confused by the
description
by um mr moore of this amendment
that i just have more questions and i
guess my first question is
what amendment are we working from
because the one that was posted in the
general court website was
1237 h do i understand that is correct
that is the number okay it is the same
one
but it sounds like mr moore made
additional changes
no what happened was there was a a
mistake that was made
and so the previous number was 1191
that so members had seen that that was
not made to the public and no you never
saw that one so
but 37 is the one where we're looking at
right now
so the way i understand it now is that
it completely changes the direct
shipping law
and now i'm reading it in a very
different context than i was before so a
couple questions i have there was a fee
previously and it looks like there's no
longer
in fact it says there won't be a fee um
going forward um is that
is that because what we're doing is
we're creating a new entity called
uh direct to the consumer
and um this might be confusing but we'll
just simply the best way we can describe
it is the direct shipper
is um for anybody who is not
licensed in new hampshire but is selling
alcohol outside of the state
that's what the direct shipping law was
and yes there was the eight percent tax
this section this direct to the consumer
is only for new hampshire licensees and
for new hampshire licensees
they can ship directly to a consumer
they're already paying their taxes
whatever
if it's 30 cents a gallon or you know
wine the five percent
so they're already paying the tax so
there's no need for us to collect
another tax
and this is only for new hampshire
licensees
who are shipping to new hampshire
citizens
i
uh we're understand going to double tax
but it isn't everything
i'm not double taxing nobody isn't there
a fee for the out of state
because we don't license them okay so
these
there but there's already licensed all
these people
okay currently okay um
all right so the other question i have i
got really confused about the discussion
of
tracking um names and all of that
um and the concern around that and so i
pulled out the form
and it looks like now the liquor
commission doesn't even
require um
uh shipment reports are no longer
required
when you apply for a direct shipper
license
so i'm i'm wondering how you can even
figure any of this information out
if these reports are now saying you
don't even need to send a shipment
report you just need to put in the
um approximate the cost okay
um so i i'm pretty sure aidan's not
ready to
answer that question but i know mark
armageddon
is on and he hears that question
and um and i'll make sure that mark
follows up and we get an answer to that
for you so i mean the question it would
be there is how would you even track
the tax at this point because you don't
even you're not even listing it out
yeah what form are you looking at do you
have i'm looking at the one right on the
website when you look up direct shipping
it says direct shipper form and in
red says very clearly
shipment reports are no longer required
okay i will we'll get an answer for you
on that one
so i i think that's going to be a big
question because
you know how do you even estimate it at
this point um
the let's see the other question i have
is that this
is a new basically i understand what
you're trying to do but it's somewhat of
a new licensing category with therefore
more demands
so regarding the compliance checks that
they're doing
um it's somewhat limited because it's
out of state
does the liquor commission have enough
uh staff and resources to
um do the compliance check now that
basically it's open to anyone in new
hampshire
you'll have to ask the senate finance
and health finance how they're
how they want to get rid of all those
auditors all the enforcement so
i cannot answer to that question of
whether you know i
don't know i mean i think that
regardless of i mean if they get rid of
the 21 positions and they're really
going to be in trouble
but at least as is now i'd just like to
know the answer if they will have
an additional um demand for
enforcement i i would say no
so is that the state the statement from
the liquor commission
that's my statement i'm saying in the
commission
i have no doubt in my mind that the
commission is always going in front of
the
legislature and say they need more
enforcement and they need more people
i'm sure they always say that but you
know that that
that's that's not our responsibility
commerce is responsibility our con we're
the policy committee and
in terms of how well the departments do
this
evidently the the our house finance
committee
thinks that that there that uh
that they can be done without
enforcement so well i guess that breaks
the question answer that question i
can't i cannot answer that for you
and i don't know if there's a revised
special note on that too
because along with that question too i
just wonder about the changes in the
taxes with the definition of the
specialty
um sorry with the new definition of
beverage manufacturer i'm not sure where
that came from that
was not in any previous discussion but
this is
my question now is is this spirits as
well
so you can um shift around
your um categories now because you all
fall under beverage what happens to the
specialty beverage
from last year and these are
these are i i i hear where you're going
and i understand your confusion and i
understand you're trying to create
confusion
but i will have to assure you that uh
that that this is all well thought out
um
that you know and and i can certainly
talk you offline
and help walk you through each one of
these issues
i think it's you know it's just
difficult because this
uh these amendments really haven't some
of these haven't been discussed at all
with stakeholders and so this would just
be another reason to remember
all the stakeholders i've absolutely
been here i realized that a new future
is a stakeholder
and last time i checked your your
stakeholder is that you're opposed to
all of this
so um so i'm not sure how much more i
can include you
in the process and feeling comfortable
with it but the whole reason i'm
held this hearing today and why we're
doing this is that that had everyone had
an opportunity
to come in and and i can assure you that
all stakeholders
barring new futures position uh are
are are in support of what we're doing
here so it wasn't
anticipated that way to work with the
other stakeholders
it was anticipated and they were
anticipated and they were invited to
testify
okay so if you've got if you know
somebody else who has a problem with
this build please
let them know contact me and i'll
certainly i'll hold another one if you
want another hearing you'll have another
one of these hearings we can do that if
there's somebody who needs more detail
more information or understanding but
like i said if you
um i mean i can see the attendees list
you know obviously i guess you can't see
it but
i pretty much everybody and anybody he
is he's they're there
they're all there they're all they know
this is happening and
they're all in in accordance with it
yeah so i guess
i guess my point is it's you know if
some people saw this
and got agreement before others then
it's just too bad there wasn't an
opportunity for
us to weigh in as well i think there are
parts of the amendment we don't have any
problems with
well let me pose the question to you is
there anything in this build this
amendment that you agree with
uh yeah i i think as the form that i saw
last week i actually was feeling much
better about it
and now i saw this and it's so different
from the bill that was
um last week but we think we made it
better here so
so okay well i would just encourage the
committee to look closely at some of
these questions and i'll be curious to
get a response from the liquor
commission on my questions
fair enough uh representative anthony do
you have a question
uh i do thank you mark i'm sorry i was
going to check this myself and and i
real i wanted to hear kate's
um kate's queries and and comments
because i do respect what she has to say
uh so my question is a nuts and bolts
question sb14 does anyone recall
that's uh senator sanders i believe it
was direct shipping
was that rolled into this and i couldn't
that is the separate issue because
that's
direct dealing with just the liquor
commission
getting into the direct shipping and so
it doesn't have anything to do with any
of these
these these okay thank you i was going
to check it myself as i said i
wanted to listen so thank you yeah fair
enough
and representative herbert
thank you chairman hunt um this is uh
the finance committee uh if i understand
you correctly
has basically gutted the uh
investigative force over at liberty
enforcement division yes
the enforcement division um
i find that very troublesome yeah i and
especially from a standing committee
that supposedly
is uh trying to make uh
you know laws in reference to
uh that have big revenue impacts
so i i don't know you can i can assure
you
that they know that uh i have let let
them know in no uncertain terms that i
are going down does not make any sense
to me that the enforcement plays a very
important
role in um our making the liquor
commission
work they were hanging their hat
on the audit um and i have a lot of
problems with that audit
and and i've pointed out to them for
example
one of the issues they were very
concerned about as they talk about
how um how you know some businesses
never have never don't get audited
and and uh you know how how can we
be doing this if we don't audit
everybody and i pointed out to them that
um another uh new hampshire tax you know
other than
like we have a rooms and meals tax and i
have been in the vacation rental
business
for almost 15 years now and
uh i have never been audited so uh the
idea to
to get rid of the auditing department
because they haven't used it
doesn't seem you know doesn't make any
sense to me but you know that
is their position um and we can only
hope that when the bill comes
out you know when the one and two come
out of the senate
um this section will have been removed
from the bill
so keep up the good work make sure they
put some people back in there to enforce
your law
absolutely i said to him so are you
going to put in more auditors you know
if you're going to get rid of the
enforcement and they said
they just shrugged their shoulders so i
i'm not you know i'm not going to get
into you know picking a fight with
another committee but
i can assure you that i my personal i
have let them know my personal feelings
that that they have gone down the wrong
path
with this but thank you yes
keith did you wanna weigh in yeah i was
just gonna say why would you
why would you say publicly that you
haven't been audited in 15 years
well if you're not doing anything
illegal then there's no problem i
i have no need to be on it and i
certainly don't look forward to being
audited or having
it but i'm just i'm just saying that you
know if if audit
is so important to the the
finance committee they might be
questioning whether the other
even bigger department of revenue are
they doing their audits too
so but i don't know so i guess that
hasn't
had they haven't gone and drilled down
the rooms and meals but
but i do think this whole thing with the
with the tax the same using that same
tax on
on car rental companies i think we
should just get rid of that tax all
together and
i think i think that the car rental tax
was created as a short term when our
time when times were tough and
i don't think it brings in a lot of
money and i think we should just
repeal the tax all together and that
would solve without
bill problem so if we just keep reducing
the revenue
and um over year after year um where are
we going to meet our obligations
and meals revenue has gone through the
roof and you know the liquor commission
is delivering plenty of money
i mean i you know i mean like i say for
myself i mean i
you know i i you know i pay
over fifteen thousand dollars a year in
in rooms tax you know
so they're they're you know the only
paychecks if you make money
uh i only know i only pay taxes if i've
rent
the tax is direct it doesn't have any
whether i make money or not
that's the bet that's a different tax
that i have to pay
so at any rate um we all set everybody
comfortable and so we'll see you all
next thursday
business profits tax the b-e-t people
can lose money and still have to pay
v-e-t
that's correct that's right okay
thank you all and uh